What do Samsung Electronics CEO Lee Kun-hee,...
...figure skater Kim Yuna and Girls' Generation members Yoona and Sooyoung have in common?
They were all born in the Year of the Horse,...
...and people born under this sign in the Chinese zodiac...
...are said to be outgoing, energetic and clever with ingenious communication techniques.
But there's more to it than that and if you want to know more,...
...you can head over to the National Folk Museum of Korea,...
...which is marking the Year of the Horse with an exhibition...
...to help visitors understand what it's all about.
The New Year will be the Year of the Horse.
The horse is a dynamic animal, so with that in mind, we devised this exhibition...
...to help people understand what a big part of our lives and culture horses are.
Visitors will have a chance to see how horses in Korea...
...from the Joseon Dynasty to the present day...
...were used and what they looked like on different occasions.
Through this exhibition, we had a chance...
...to learn about different types of horses and their characteristics.
There are dozens of artifacts, tools and other implements on display,...
...with detailed information about each piece and how it was used.
The exhibition is scheduled to run through February 17th.
The Year of the Horse gives us a fresh start,...
...a clean slate to make up for our mistakes and fulfill our goals.
Kim Hyun-bin, Arirang News.